sie alle wollen auf und davon
familie dobler aus dem thurgau sucht das
große abenteuer in australien und
hansjörg eger aus dem aargau bauen in
thailand eine seniorenresidenz familie
tänzer aus dem kanton bern träumt von
einer besseren leben und wagt den
neuanfang in florida wiedersehen mit
hermann schönbächler der peter förster
und seine familie haben das glück tief
im kanadischen wald gefunden
[Musik]
von solchen momenten hat kley tänzer
immer geträumt
er genießt die ruhigen morgenstunden von
florida vor ihm liegt ein weiterer tag
an dem er nicht tut was er muss sondern
was er will seine tochter larissa hat
sich parat gemacht für die schule ihr
unterricht beginnt bereits um viertel
nach sieben
[Musik]
seehofers
aufgeweckt ging es letzte woche zu und
her ihm auf und davon
nach der abenteuerreise durch ihre neue
heimat kehrte familie tobler zurück nach
hause an die australische westküste in
thailand weiten lanier und hansjörg eger
zusammen mit den ersten mieterinnen
ihrer seniorenresidenz die geister
häuschen ein
sie gelten als wohnsitz der ahnen und
sollen glück bringen
in kanada verdiente hermann schönbächler
sein geld nicht nur als förster
gesammelte pilze die er als begehrte
delikatesse teuer verkaufen konnte
dennis tänzer tat sich schwer mit den
start in ihr neues leben
noch fehlte ihr die lockerheit die ihre
familie in florida bereits wenigsten
könnte
[Musik]
larissa dancer hat sich trotz der
fremden sprache gut eingelebt in ihrer
schule
sobald das auch
vergiss nicht schlafen
clyde denzer darf nicht einmal
aussteigen wenn er seine tochter zur
schule bringt so wollen es die
vorschriften
[Musik]
ich liebe ruf gestanden zur pause und
das motiviert mich schon zum
tagesgeschäft graf und mit der wortwahl
ist das eigentlich gut der berufung der
unterlegene änderung
heute will kleid denzel das ferienhaus
auf hochglanz bringen
die auswanderer haben es mit dem geld
aus dem hausverkauf in der schweiz
bezahlt künftig wollen sie es vermieten
und so einen teil ihres einkommens
bestreiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die seniorenresidenz von lany und hans
jörg jäger ist fast fertig gebaut
die ersten bungalows sind bewohnt das
restaurant ist in betrieb doch die
auswanderer haben nervenaufreibende
wochen hängt das ich immer wieder hatten
heftige regenfälle den bau verzögert
heute wollen sie ihre sorgen für einige
stunden verdrängen und können sich einen
freien nachmittag
[Musik]
dem ausland
melanie jäger fährt ihre haare die sie
extra in container aus der schweiz
mitgebracht hat inklusive hager
nummernschild
ihr mann hans jörg hat es eine harley
verkauft und mit dem geld den bau eines
bungalows finanziert jetzt fährt er eine
alte runde
es ist heiss schweiz trainierte wahnsinn
habe sie laut news na ja das ist so
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass der film ein sie ihn
zurück
von der bauarbeiten muss das klar
[Musik]
dies ist für hermann schönbächler
lebensqualität automotive weil es
irgendwo trees kilometer im biberacher
hüsli ja aber habe
mit einem 1909
das ist natürlich ein porsche
[Musik]
ein säugling hat angebissen
das ist die idee zum fest christina
schönbächler hat bald geburtstag und da
will man die partygäste mit geräuchertem
fisch verwöhnen
doch ausgerechnet heute bleibt es bei
dem einen fall
[Musik]
seit sie vor fünf monaten die schweiz
verliessen waren denen und kevin tobler
nicht mehr in der schule für ihre
freunde in der schweiz pausieren sie in
ihren neuen schuluniformen bereits
morgen gilt es für den zehnjährigen
dylan ernst strengen vater rolf dobler
hat sein bestes hemd aus dem schrank
geholt um seine familie ernähren zu
können muss der bodenleger bald geld
verdienen
sie haben zwar viel gespart für ihren
traum doch das leben in australien ist
nicht billig rolf thode will einen
speziellen schweizer bodenbelag nach
australien importieren von einem
einflussreichen architekten will er
wissen ob seine geschäftsidee eine
chance hat der bodenbelag des thurgauers
ist zwar doppelt so teuer wie ein
australischer dafür hält er auch doppelt
so lange und erfüllt höchste ansprüche
etwa beim brandschutz architekt
berufsverbot ist beeindruckt er sieht
sehr wohl eine marktnische für den
schweizer auswanderer
[Musik]
es ist gut ist nach nehme die
produktvielfalt gibt man aber ich war ja
nicht die haben wir durch siege von
quadratmetern familie zu verbringen dort
sein strahlen wenn wir nur zwei drei
objekte mit dem produkt dann wäre der
super-gau positiv alles klappt mit der
klappe
[Musik]
sie hatte einen schwierigen start
doch mittlerweile ist dennis tänzer
glücklich in ihrer neuen heimat
sie muss aber auch nicht wäre tochter
franka für die schule ende büffeln für
krank als schulweg müssen die beiden
einige minuten mehr einrechnen
die zwölfjährige ist auf dem
swimmingpool rand des ferienhauses
ausgerutscht und hat sich das bein
gebrochen
[Applaus]
auch dennis tänzer darf nicht aussteigen
wenn sie ihre tochter in die schule
bringt das war selbst am ersten tag so
stolz wie sich das mancher scott günstig
und pancho hatte sich zuerst sorgen
gemacht wegen der vielen alligatoren in
florida doch jetzt macht ihm vor allem
die hitze zu schaffen
yang jiechi
[Musik]
dennis tänzer brauchte zeit um sich an
ihre neue heimat zu gewöhnen
mittlerweile konnte sich kaum mehr
vorstellen florida wieder zu verlassen
der lockere lebensstil gefällt ihr
[Musik]
spitze
in thailand sind bereits vier bungalows
der seniorenresidenz bewohnt
doch hans jörg jäger hat wenig grund zur
freude
er besucht eine seine mieterin die
deutsche fanny sie hat sich bereits nach
wenigen wochen entschieden ihren
mietvertrag wieder aufzulösen
ihr ist es hier auf dem land schlicht zu
ruhig eine schwierige situation für
hansjörg eger
es ist straßenprofi für heller ja
einfach super to the beat
wir haben uns sehr gut verstanden also
nicht das abreiben miranda gemerkt dass
das haben die auf lange zeit ungewiss
neben der deutschen verlassen zwei
weitere mieterinnen die seniorenresidenz
wieder auch sie haben sie falsche
vorstellungen gemacht
hier auf dem land findet man natur und
tradition shoppingmeilen und
touristenstrände sucht man vergebens
[Musik]
ja wünsche ich dir auch nicht weinen was
du liebst du das hat nichts mit dem zu
tun hat nichts mit dem zu tun das ist
auch nicht für alles verantwortlich hier
klar
[Musik]
ein trost bleibt es haben sich bereits
weitere sensoren bei lenny und hans jörg
jäger gemeldet die sich für ihre
residenz interessieren
[Musik]
stürmische zeiten auch in kanada ein
jahr nach dem verheerenden unwetter
braut sich schon wieder etwas zusammen
und das ausgerechnet an christina
schönbächlers 38 geburtstag
bis jetzt lässt ihre geburtstags
bescherung zu wünschen übrig
[Musik]
christine schönbächlers toller hecht hat
er immerhin an der blick dass jetzt
nicht die hauptkasse xxi mit jeder als
rabbiner materie
das waren nur wirkt hatte das auch
versuchen die fischfilets liegen einige
stunden im rauch
[Musik]
es ist mit der september das thermometer
zeigt knapp über null grad als christine
schönbächler ihren gästen zum apero den
fisch serviert freundin caroline die
anderen partygäste sind begeistert von
hermann schönbächlers räucherfisch
[Gelächter]
irgendwann wird es selbst den
abgehärteten kanadiern zu kalt draußen
[Musik]
wünsche und liebe
ja
[Musik]
an der australischen westküste hat dylan
tobler seinen ersten schultag
der zehnjährige ist froh dass ihn seine
eltern und sein großer bruder begleiten
kevin wird morgen eingeschult vom
eigenartigen pult zum aufklappen bis zum
schulheft hier in australien ist alles
anders als er sich denen aus der schweiz
gewohnt war
[Musik]
zum glück lernte denen schon während der
abenteuerreise durch seine neue heimat
einige brocken englisch
wenn ich meine fehler machen
für die ersten wochen bekommt denen eine
hilfs lehrerin
sie unterstützt ihn beim schreiben die
kinder sollen einen großen wunsch
formulieren
dylan will motocrossfahrer werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schon nach wenigen schulstunden hat
dylan erste freunde gefunden nur wie
deren lieblingsspiel funktioniert
versteht er zuerst nicht das hat der
zehnjährige von seinen eltern gelernt
nur wer etwas wagt findet das glück
[Musik]
witzigmann steioff dem herz kein schönes
gefühl wenn man zeit ist alles hängt ihm
so schnell akzeptiert das ist so wohl
fühlen oder ex wochen geschlossen
probiert
[Musik]
berlin
larissa und franca tänzer haben sich in
der schule eingelebt johannes und clyde
das haus fertig eingerichtet in florida
hat die familie die anstrengendsten
wochen überstanden
heute besuchen die auswanderer eine der
hauptattraktionen ihrer neuen heimat die
weltberühmten everglades
[Musik]
das naturreservat kann nur mit
speziellen propeller booten befahren
werden
die wasserwege zwischen den mangroven
sind oft nur wenige zentimeter tief
[Musik]
in florida leben rund zwei millionen
alligatoren
sie können bis zu 100 jahre alt werden
die 80 zähne des alligators bekräftigen
den waschbär in seinem bestreben nie
aber auch wirklich nie ins wasser zu
fallen
die ersten wochen in florida waren für
die familie eine regelrechte
schleuderpartie vor allem dennis tänzer
hatte mühe mit dem tempo ihres mannes
mitzuhalten
[Musik]
mittlerweile sitzt die familie nicht nur
beim wochenendausflug wieder im gleichen
boot neues leben
[Musik]
das geld heraus
der tierpfleger versichert diese
alligator habe sein fressen heute schon
bekommen
[Musik]
obwohl drei ihre mieterinnen bereits
wieder abgereist sind haben lange und
hansjörg eger den mut nicht verloren
sie treffen die letzten vorbereitungen
für die eröffnungsfeier ihrer
seniorenresidenz residenz
[Musik]
nach sieben monaten bauzeit ist auch das
hotel ihrer seniorenresidenz fertig im
parterre haben lange und hansjörg eger
ihr büro eingerichtet
hier will der aargauer seine rede für
die eröffnungsfeier üben immerhin
erwarten sie die schweizer botschafterin
seit über zehn jahren träumen meine frau
und ich von einer kleinen pfeilen
präsident wenn er lese nur das prägte er
muss nicht nur an einer puppe muss seine
augen bedruckt ja ja das ist trainiert
dann muss alles sehr geehrte frau
botschafterin sehr geehrt die gäste aus
nah und werden
es freut mich außerordentlich dass sie
alle da ihr euch begrüßen zu dürfen ist
offen
der traum ist in erfüllung gegangen sind
überzeugt dass mir diese werte machen
musste sagte geiger
du lachst machte dominant dank sprach
sie hat es ermöglicht dass ein traum nun
wirklichkeit geworden ist sie hat auch
die mini verträge durchgesetzt hätten
bremsen und getriebe clooney als idole
sind wahrlich übermenschliches geleistet
eigentlich ist die tränen ausgebrochen
wenn petrus griff der klugheit
da sind die hand objekt sie wurde mit
fragte haben es richtig gemacht
als ihr dann gesagt dass gott wieder
lange dafür möchte ich möchte dir ganz
herzlich danken
ich will hier raus
[Musik]
kevin tobler ist in einem alter in dem
man stark mit sich selbst beschäftigt
ist
jetzt musste er auch noch sein ganzes
leben neu erfinden
über den verlust seiner alten
schulfreunde tröstete sich der 15
jährige stets mit der aussicht in der
neuen heimat kite surfen zu lernen
eine mischung aus wellenreiten und
drachen fliegen
denn
keinem in der familie fiel der abschied
von der schweiz so schwer wie kevin
wir werden da man bedenkt wie vor allem
an ihm ist klar dass das nicht stimmen
dass auch die tui gehe ich habe doch und
einem bickelheimer profitum zeit geld
jede 25 in 2010 zeichneten vorläufigen
wir machen alles für die jugend wichtig
ist dass ihr glück jetzt singt und aber
halt nur im 23 mann fit und wir gewalt
wirklich oder und einfach in der schule
ganz mittelamerika der freundschaft das
richtige freunde finden und jetzt fand
ihn sehr gerne tool erkennt wie king und
wenn im frack hörst du jetzt wieder das
freizügige schweizer zeitnah auf einem
pfand nein im fall werde
kitesurfen ist ein gefährlicher sport
immer wieder kommt es zu schweren
unfällen wenn server die gewalt des
windes unterschätzen
darum üben anfänger wie kevin noch ohne
scharf brett
mega cool sie zum dank für das kalte
snacks informationen und 30
[Musik]
sonnencreme und badehose haben christina
und hermann schönbächler in kanada ganz
unten im schrank versorgt
also der astronomische winter angefangen
und so schneeberger homepage trinken
aufführungsorte georg seiten ist es wert
diesen konter winter mit wenig schnee
aber wie 60 ist seit er umgekehrt bin
ich aber schon kinder knipsen
der kleine riese und seine schwester
natascha verbringen die meiste zeit
draußen egal bei welchem wetter ganz
ganz froh dass i - hängt möglichkeit
trageser hof zwar möglich in busse mit
mit den beiden oder hoch spuren im
winter oder der wolf
osamu und trotzdem im grundgesetz ohne
große umstände ich hoffe ich wirklich
das ist es die konstellation
[Gelächter]
von marc schmunzeln wenn hermann
schönbächler immer wieder die ultimative
lebensqualität gespürt die er mit seiner
familie in kanada gefunden habe
doch was gibt es schöneres für die
kinder als im selbstgebauten iglu mit
mami und papi schweizer schokolade zu
naschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit einer unfreiwilligen rutschpartie
geht es nächste woche weiter bei auf und
davon
christina und hermann schönbächler
drehen durch
in thailand empfangen lange und hansjörg
eger zur eröffnung ihrer
seniorenresidenz schwergewichtigen
besuch in florida erwarten denn ich so
ein kleid dancer die ersten mieter ihres
ferienhauses höchste zeit alles auf
hochglanz zu bringen
große überraschungen in australien
familie tobler zieht schon wieder um die
thurgauer verwirklichen im outback ihren
traum von einer eigenen farm
[Musik]
muss ich die gerne wieder mit der figur
träumen
[Musik]